what's good everybody Michael from
GameSpot here at the Sony headquarters
in San Mateo California checking out the
upcoming PlayStation VR games let's
check it out let's go
[Music]
this is the first look anyone's ever had
of the game the persistence which is a
first-person survival horror psvr game
that plays very similarly to Resident
Evil 7 best that kind of reminds me of
System Shock almost where you're going
through a spaceship with humans that
have been transformed into horrible
monsters and one really nice feature
about this is that you can have four of
your friends jump on through a companion
app that's available on any tablet or
smartphone and they can control anything
within your environment so they have the
option to either assist you throughout
the ship or they can screw around with
you and trick you or or mess up your
playthrough and make it even more
challenging generally it makes for a fun
more inclusive experience with VR though
it was a bear experience at first with
only sparse enemies and linear
environments I do expect that the game
will flesh out a little bit more as you
move on the next game I got to play was
star blood arena which is a competitive
shooter game where you're in a vessel
and you have multiple weapons in a
three-dimensional space you can go up
down left right and move throughout the
environment to play it essentially a
deathmatch type of game I got to hook up
with a couple of the developers to play
an eight-player deathmatch and it's a
pretty straightforward experience where
you get different loadouts you can
customize your characters put decals on
your flying mechs the only problem I
would have with this is that if you're
susceptible to motion sickness in VR
this may be a tough experience to have
since there is a lot of movement along
the x and y and z-axes
at a very fast pace but if you're not
susceptible to motion sickness this may
be an interesting psvr experience
fantastic contraption has been out on
oculus and vibe for a while now but it's
finally coming to psvr
what's different about the psvr version
is that since we don't have room scale
experiences we can now change the size
of our playground and zoom in on
different areas of the map and control
and rotate it with our PS Move
controllers so we still get that full
game without having to compromise with
the fact that we don't have room scale
so if you're familiar with this game you
play with the set of tools and you build
different vehicles and well contraptions
to move an object to a certain goal it
was one of the highlights of VR last
year and you can experience this now in
PlayStation VR one game I play that
really stood out was static which is a
VR puzzle based game with with a device
strapped to your hand and you really
have to figure out what the controls do
throughout each puzzle what I really
appreciated about this game is that it
didn't tell you anything up front it was
up to you to experiment not just with
the controls but with what the game
requires you to solve in terms of the
puzzles it took me about a good 10 15
minutes to not only get a grasp of the
controls but figure out which what each
aspect of the puzzle does and what
you're asked to do
it's almost reminiscent of the witness
where you're dumped into this world to
figure things out on your own
and the aesthetic almost reminds me of
portal where it's very sterile and a lab
type experience I do expect the game to
change up its mechanics and its level
design and what it asks you to do
throughout the game but we'll find out
when it does come out far point is
PlayStation VR is much-anticipated
sci-fi shooter and we got to play a new
level here today using the PlayStation
VR aim controller which is new
peripheral designed to simulate an
actual gun the peripheral itself is
fairly lightweight it's accurate and
it's tracking and has all the full set
of buttons it works well for Farpoint
but what we got to play in the game
didn't stand out too much from other
shooters we've seen in VR but we did get
to play some co-op which i think is
where this game will really stand out
and those are all the games we checked
out today if you like this video
subscribe to our channel like the video
share with your friends and stay tuned
to gain spot comm for more coverage of
the latest games